okay good morning uh today we do China
um obviously we are in China and we will
we know a lot of Chinese history so I
will go fairly quickly and deeply this
is an opportunity for us to look back on
the theories we've developed um over the
course of this year and
really think about how they apply to the
Chinese context it's a chance for us to
see if models work if they do work then
they would be true in the western
context and also in the Chinese context
it's also a chance for us to deeply
interrogate uh our theories and see
where flaws might arise okay so um I'll
be I'll be going through some Chinese
history but I will do so um by applying
the theories we've learned so far mainly
the oceanic currents of History right so
let's get started today we're going to
look at a
question um that is fundamental to China
which is we know that for the longest
time China really was the Civilized
civilization par excellence in the world
um it gave us all the great inventions
that would make modernity possible
including the compass paper print making
gunpowder okay but after s Dynasty which
is about the year
1200 um chying to stop being creative
and so why did this happen and that is
the question that we frame our
discussion uh this morning all
right let's go over some quick Chinese
history so um Chinese civilization as
you know developed along the Yellow
River the Yellow River um is perfect for
agriculture and and as a result
population expanded very quickly when
that happens conflict and War will ensue
and that's and that's what will give
rise to settlements and fortified cities
that will drive the development of the
state and civilization and technology
okay
um the Hallmark of China civilization is
what we call the Waring States period uh
t
CH and at this time the foundations of
Chinese civilization will come into
being at this time um you will have
something called the hund schools of
thought um confusion will develop as
well thaism and legalism okay and these
ideas will form the
foundation
of Chinese
civilization and as you can see in this
period all these hundred schools of
thought developed because of a process
we call open Cooperative competition
which as we have discussed is a main
driver of innovation in human
civilization okay openness means that
there is no centralized
Authority cooperation means that even
though there's no centralized Authority
the different states are trading
communicating with each other and they
are intermarrying into each other and
competition means that there is a lot of
conflict between them they're they are
Waring against each other for dominance
in their
region okay and in this process this
will give rise to the ideas the
technology the values the culture that
will underpin China civilization for the
next 2,000
years confusion is obviously uh who is
best remembered from this era but you
also have l who is the founder of
DSM okay as well as J and
M uh Su will at this time write his book
The Art of
War so in a process that is open
Cooperative competition
eventually one state will emerge to
conquer the rest and as we discussed why
the state emerges is because of three
things energy they're much more
energetic they're much more ambitious
second is openness they're much more
willing to adopt
innovation in the ruthless pursuit of
military conquest and they are
opportunistic meaning meaning that they
will uh do whatever it takes to win okay
so in this period the state that will
eventually conquer all China and create
the first Empire is the
ching and again um if you think about it
in the year 500 BC we canot possibly
predict that the Ching would conquer and
unite all of China because of all these
states the Ching was the
uh porest it was situated in the
mountains whereas the other states are
situated in these fertile
valleys
um its culture was not as developed as
the rest and its population was
smaller so we couldn't predict that the
Ching would eventually unite all of
China but at the same time near 500 we
cannot have predicted that Rome would
unite the Mediterranean and we canot
have predicted that Macedonia would have
United the Greek world all right so
let's discuss very quickly why the Ching
was able to succeed okay even though
this is the Waring States period And
there's a lot of warfare going on what
we need to remember is that this Warfare
is heavily
regulated war in this period it's almost
like an aristocratic aristocratic gay
okay so there are stories where
um this General was leading lead laying
Siege to a city and the people inside
were starving to death which is what you
do in a Siege right you starve the
population to death but the general felt
tremendous regret and guilt for putting
the
population uh under such misery so he
retreated and withw to give time for the
population to recover and that was
considered what was gentleman
okay that was what what was considered
shiver um civilized back then another
story is that an army was crossing the
river which is a great time to attack
them but the opposing Army let them
cross the river because that is what is
civilized okay what is gentlemanly so
this
period um was heavily regulated by a
gentleman's uh code of conduct okay and
then then you ask yourself why is that
the case and the answer is that remember
this is a a open Cooperative competition
environment in which even though these
states are at War there's still a lot of
intermarriage between them there's still
a lot of trade a lot of communication so
these states are not trying to use
Warfare to overturn the social order
because they benefit from the status quo
they're using Warfare as a means to
maintain the social order
and that's why Warfare is extremely
heavily regulated okay and so let's
think about the pelian war between
Athens and
Sparta uh when we looked at the war we
know that the pal pipan war was
extremely bloody it was extremely deadly
but at the same time it was extremely
regulated now a lot of their strategies
didn't really make any sense it was
really about defeating the enemy so for
example know that in Sparta there there
are people called the helots who are
basically slaves to the Spartan people
and the helots Outnumber the Spartans 10
to one so all Athens had to do was say
the hots if you fight for us if you
revolt against your Masters we will
grant you Freedom that's all Athens had
to do but Athens never did that because
because by doing doing that you would
disrupt the social order from which
Athens benefited and you unleash a
revolution that could possibly engulf
the entire Greek World also even though
Sparta and Athens were enemies they were
United by
intermarriage among their Elites they
they had a similar culture and they um
historically were allies especially
against the the Persians okay so Warfare
at this time was about maintaining the
status quo rather than overturning the
status quo and this presents an
opportunity for the Ching Dynasty which
H is in the margins of the status quo
right so the Ching Dynasty start to
implement Warfare in a way that
opportunistically took advantage of the
status quo
situation and they commit themselves to
total warfare meaning their entire
Society was engineered in a way to allow
them to win against your enemies okay so
certain characteristics about the Ching
Dynasty at this time uh first is the
idea of legalism right Draconian laws
that force a population to behave in a
certain way something that um is very
fundamental the idea of legalism is
collective responsibility what that
means is that if you commit a crime
you'll be punished but so will your
entire family okay the idea of
collective responsibility is Pioneer at
this time in in order to maintain a very
strict uh society that can be purposed
for war okay so that's the first thing
um legalism second thing is the idea of
centralization meaning that you have a
bureaucracy uh you have
standardization okay um and this allows
you to actually expand very quickly it
allows you to expand and govern new
territories that you uh conquer
and the third of course is Total War
meaning like you devote all your
resources to Warfare in order to conquer
your enemies the Ching dynasty was also
known for its openness so if you were a
man of talent and you can contribute to
their military and their bureaucracy
they would welcome you okay so think of
the Ching as a revolutionary system that
sought to overturn the status quo and
the other other uh States like we Jan
and and two especially two they were
trying to maintain the status quo and
therefore they were not that well
equipped to deal with the Challenge from
uh the Ching okay now we know that the
Ching would unite all of
China and but because their system was
so Draconian eventually the other states
would rebel against them and this would
eventually lead to the um Han Dynasty
okay now the Han Dynasty um is actually
well even though the Han Dynasty
disparages the Ching right so our very
conception of the Ching comes from Han
historians who tell us that the Ching
buried Scholars and they burned books
and that's exteme and that in our eyes
is barbaric right we don't know if
that's true we know that the Ching
practice heavy censorship so those 100
Schools of thought a lot of these books
were censored and destroyed during this
period but we don't know for a fact that
they buried Scholars okay but this is
what but so the Han Dynasty is trying to
disparage trying to refute the Ching
Dynasty that said the Han Dynasty
continues the system first introduced by
the um K okay the Han is really at this
point the height of of Chinese
civilization there's a confidence
there's an arrogance to the Han and one
of the top priorities for the Han is now
that they've United China they have to
deal with the northern steps people okay
remember that throughout history the
steps people have proven to be the most
daunting challenge for civilizations
they are extremely um they're they're
ferocious Warriors and the step people
will eventually give rise to the Mongols
at this point the main adversary of the
Han are called the Shong new people and
the Han Dynasty is committed to a policy
of eradication against the shungu okay
and this policy of eradication will
force the shunu to migrate westwards and
eventually they will these people will
uh start to even threaten Rome um itself
AA
hun the H people are descendants of the
jungu okay but over time um because of
this conflict between the Han and the
northern step people this will create
tremendous strain on the Han and
eventually the policy will evolve to one
of
cooperation and dependency and um so
what will happen is there'll be a lot of
trade uh there'll be a lot of
intermarriage um and and the and the
step people will be hired as mercenaries
for internal conflicts within China okay
so um open qual competition now switches
from Mahan which has become a
centralized power to the step people so
Within These people and there's quite
quite a lot of different tribes there
will be now tremendous competition and
one group one tribe that will eventually
Triumph is called the Shan Bay okay and
the Shan B will give rise to which
Dynasty do you guys
know
H uh okay which but shamb will give rise
to which major Chinese
dynasty you guys should know this what
comes after the
thean the tongue Dynasty okay so this is
one one thing um that is misunderstood
the Han Dynasty is really the last
Chinese dynasty it is the last
ethnically Chinese dynasty committed to
the protection and propagation of
Chinese culture the tong Dynasty um the
founders the Lee family they're actually
the of the shandai tribe okay and as a
result they will switch from a they will
switch China into a universal
Multicultural Empire okay the tongue
Dynasty is famous for being extremely
open tolerant and and inclusive
okay all right so this is the tong
Dynasty which is considered the height
of power height of Chinese power in the
world uh the tong Dynasty will try to
expand Westwoods into Central Asia um
and it will start the Silk Road and
trade networks all around the world um
Buddhism at this point will come into
China and it will become um at certain
points a state religion okay but the
there are many problems with the tongue
Dynasty um so there's a heavy Reliance
on generals to fight Wars and this will
eventually lead to the unan Rebellion
okay which lasts for uh almost 10 years
Anan is the top general of the tong
Dynasty and because he's given too much
power and he has too much Independence
he's much too trusted by the emperor he
eventually rebells and 60 uh throne for
himself okay this Rebellion will
kill um anywhere between a third to half
of the tongue population okay 60 million
to 30 million people and this is this is
devastating and traumatic for the tong
Dynasty okay but somehow it
recovers but uh but then but then you
will have another Rebellion called a
hangcha Rebellion which will end the
tongue Dynasty I'll talk about the hang
later on okay um the tongue Dynasty will
give rise to the S
Dynasty um and the S Dynasty Will adopt
a policy of diplomacy
tribute uh assimilation with the
northern tribes okay they're trying to
avoid the Trap of the tongue where you
give too much power to General and the
general will Rebel Okay so a lot of
power the S Dynasty so at the time of
the S Dynasty a lot of power will be
invested in the Imperial bureaucracy
okay that's a
song um eventually song Empire will be
carved up and conquered uh event the
ultimate winners of this war will be the
Mongols who in the year 1279 conquers
entirety of the S Empire and unite China
okay but the y the Mongols are
considered a foreign
Dynasty so I mentioned that the tongue
Dynasty is actually um non non-chinese
but the
Mongols understood themselves to be
non-chinese and as a result they
discriminated against Chinese people
which ultimately led to Rebellion that
will establish the Ming Empire and
eventually the Ming Empire will give way
to the Ching Empire the Manus are just
another iteration of the Mongol people
um they will rule China until 1911 when
the Empire is overthrown a republic is
established and this gives way to of
course the People's Republic of China
okay so the big question again we're
looking at is why is it that the Song
Dynasty is the last creative Dynasty all
right and if we use the idea of open
Cooperative competition
then we know the answer all right and
the answer is this um previous dynasties
were not able to exert National control
they were always competing against other
states within China proper okay so you
look at the Han Dynasty well the Han
Dynasty would give way to dozens of
other states that would compete against
each other okay so in theory the ching
and the on United China but not for
long all
right and the same is true for the
tongue as as well China uh for the
longest time was just too large too
diverse to be unified centrally and as a
result the idea of open Cooperative
competition would still give rise to
Innovation but starting at the time of
the song we see a radical change look at
the look at the song okay the song is
pretty uh United and the uran is
extremely United so the UN Dynasty is
able to unite all of China and then
after the UN Dynasty the Ming is also
pretty United and the Ching is extremely
United okay so in other words the answer
is this after the song and starting with
the uran China
became uh nationally unified and it was
able the center was able to exert
control of the provin provinces in a way
that was not true before in Chinese
history okay so the idea of open
competitive competition died with the
Song Dynasty and that's why after the
song trying to stop being creative okay
so that's the answer but then this gives
rise to a another question which is how
was China able
to create National unity all right all
right so to answer this question I want
to uh refer to the work of Professor
Wong yua he is a professor of Chinese
history at Harvard okay and he wrote a
new book called the rise and fall of
Imperial China and it's it and it's a
wonderful book uh if you're interested
in Chinese history I strongly recommend
that that you look at this book all
right so he begins the book by asking a
central question and the central
question is this we know that the tong
dynasty was really the height of Chinese
power it had about a quarter of the
world's
GDP and it was in and it influenced the
cultures of Korea
Japan um and it's extremely diverse
inclusive Multicultural Empire that
introduced Buddhism to China
okay but the problem with the tongue is
their Emperors didn't really live that
long five
Emperors at least five Emperors during
the tong Dynasty were deposed by the
elite the AOS they got together and were
through the emperor usually by killing
him okay so this is a tongue Dynasty but
when you look at the ching ching um only
had 5% of the world's GDP and it was
racked by internal rebellions like the
taiping
rebellion and it was far behind in terms
of of science technology to
Europe but the Emperors like tenan long
they could rule for 60 years
peacefully okay they transitioned into a
thr peacefully and they died peacefully
so the Ching even though it marked a um
a low point in Chinese Prosperity it the
emperors
lived for a long time which meant that
the bureaucracy the center was really
stable this is a
paradox okay why is it that when China
is wealthy the emperor is weak but when
the emperor is strong China is poor
that's a paradox that Professor Wong yua
is trying to answer in his
book okay so he he so I mean he is um he
used us a lot of social science analysis
and research for his book so he so first
of all what he does is he analyzes the
probability as an emperor that you're
deposed by the elite okay and it turns
out like the tongue was really the
height but then when you get to the song
the probability decreases
significantly
okay but at the same time what we need
to understand is even though the emperor
uh lived longer the state's ability to
collect taxes to control the economy
decrease over time okay so you can see
that starting the year zero all the way
down there there's a downward slope now
this is not straight down okay there are
Peaks right so so you go down then you
go up you go down the up is when a new
Dynasty starts and so at that at this
time the new Dynasty is run by a very
strong leader like for example um um Jan
Jang of the Ming Dynasty the founder of
the Ming Dynasty okay these are
extremely capable leaders and they are
supported by really talented bureaucrats
and at this point they're able to
collect a lot of taxes which strengthens
the center but over time the trend is
fairly clear starting at the time of the
song You You See a steep decline in the
state's ability to collect
taxes okay the only exceptions are
around the year 1600 when the Ming
transitions to the
Ching
okay and so what Professor W wa has
discovered is the reason why you have
this
transition
is the Emperor starting around the time
of the S he's actually figured out a way
to divide and conquer the
elite okay so the elite when they are
united they're able to promote strong
centralized policies that promot that
promote National
growth but the centralized Elite can
always threaten the Emperor who is
dependent on the elite
for um for uh uh for for their support
in the military and in government
okay starting around the song The
centralized Elite is now broken down
into localized Elite so the trick that
China has discovered in
maintaining um a strong Center is by
localizing the elites okay so the idea
is you localize the elites when you
localize Elites you can Implement a
policy we call divide and conquer okay
so you get the Elites in this province
to fight amongst themselves if they have
too busy f f fighting amongst themselves
they're not going to ever rebel against
you and they're not going to build
alliances with other provinces to ever
challenge you okay and their priorities
and focus is in the provinces and they
really don't care what you guys do in
the capital all right so that's the
thesis all right and what professor
wangas says is the main
mechanism um that the emperor used in
order to achieve this radical cultural
shift is the kuu okay the kuu is a civil
service
examination that um promoted bureaucrats
into into position of power okay the kuu
the Civil Service
examination
and so the history of the kuu is that it
was introduced briefly in a sway and
then the Tong Dynasty uh started to to
use it okay but it was really the S
Dynasty that really systemized and
promoted it okay basically the S Dynasty
in ins institutionalized the kuu okay
and before the could you it was it was
really an arist aristocratic system
where um you had to be of noble birth in
order to become a high official in
government which is true for most
cultures okay so that's what he argues
all right so um he looks at times of
major rebellions and what he shows is
that whenever there's massive climate
change you have violence erupt okay
because when you have a centralized
system what often happens is that the
nobility engage in rcking Behavior
basically they they exploit The Peasants
and that's fine if the weather is good
when when the weather is bad and
peasants don't have enough to eat they
they often Rebel okay and in the tongue
this would culminate something called
the hangcha Rebellion which would last
for 10 years when a salt Merchant in
hangcha uh sorry Assa a certain assult
Merchant named honga he would lead an
uprising that would overwhelm and
destroy the um Kong Dynasty the the the
thing that that's important for us to
remember is that he would go all the way
to changan and changan is where all the
elite live okay there about 200 aristoc
aristocratic families in the tong
Dynasty and they all killed in this
Rebellion when you remove the
aristocracy this this gives the S
Dynasty room to implement a new policy
and ensure that a nobility cannot arise
again okay so that is a significance of
the hangchow Rebellion it eliminated the
idea of aristocracy in China
okay so um Professor Wang yua he looks
what he does is he shows you how
networks work
in uh China so during the tongue Dynasty
as you can see there are centers which
then move to the provinces okay so these
families are all interconnected together
because there's only 200 aric families
if you are a wealthy family in a
province what you want to do is inter
Mar into one of these AR aristocratic
families okay because that's the best
way to ensure your advantage and
privilege in life okay so that's this is
during the tongue Dynasty when families
are united
nationally but when you get to the to
Soul Dynasty what you will see is that
the center has been localized meaning
it's been spread out and what you also
see is that these networks are are
localized they're not connected together
now nationally all right and this again
allows now the emperor to divide and
conquer all right so let's do let's just
do a comparison of the tongue and the
song as you can see what's really
important is look at this guys the
networks become more and more localized
over time it is the deliberate policy of
the Imperial bureaucracy to localize
Elite networks so that they can never
unite and challenge the center okay so
these networks are becoming much more
fractured and localized over time all
right okay so the the main benefit of
the system is of course National Unity
so again during the Han you have all
these different provinces that form
their own dynasties and which challenge
a center okay so China was in a constant
process of war the tongue dynasty was a
bit better but when you get to the S the
UN the Ming and the Ching it's all
pretty unified nationally okay by
localizing Elites you ensure the center
can't be challenged and as a result you
give a semblance of national
Unity but the problem with this as we
know is it comes at the cost of in
ination which will make China
insular poor and divided in the long
term and it's not it's not really a
sustainable system okay but that's a
system that China has chosen to adopt
for the past thousand
years right a Divine and Conquer policy
against the local
Elites all right so let's look at
another example of how China became
insular um poor divided over time so
this is a map of the top 30 cities by
population throughout Chinese history as
you can see during the Western Han
during the Hong Dynasty most of these
cities are
centered around the hango the Yellow
River okay that makes sense because
that's where Chinese Chinese
civilization began but starting by the T
time of the tongue they're starting to
spread out more and by the time of the
Soul
they're actually congregating to the
coast right so why is this happening
it's happening because of Maritime trade
initiated
by the abasa calipat okay remember last
class we learned about the Islamic
golden age and how the bass of calipat
became so wealthy that it established
trade networks all around the world and
these trade networks were so powerful
that they could influence the National
Economic Development of China
okay and we can expect that because of
Maritime trade over time all the major
cities of China would all shift to the
coast and that's
why when jul Yan Jang came into
Power he initiated a policy of close
borders he shut down Maritime trade
because he was
afraid that if this continued then all
the C all the power would be located in
the coastal areas and therefore the
north the West the South will become
much poorer and therefore they are much
more incentivized to Rebel also the
coastal uh areas uh would have so much
power that they could ultimately depose
him okay and that's why Jan uh Jan Jang
would impose a policy of Maritime trade
B and this would make China much more
insular and weak
and poor
okay so again remember back to the U
Islamic golden age when the Islamic
World United all the entire world and
Tred to pull China into its system but
because of that it was
causing uh wealth inequality in China
and that's why the Ming Dynasty will
shut down the straight network not
completely but mostly okay and that's
why you see have this massive Chinese
immigration to Southeast CH Asia because
they want to maintain the these trade
networks and there's there's a um trade
ban
enforced uh in the Ching in the sorry in
the Ming Dynasty okay and the Ching
Dynasty will continue this policy as
well for China the priority is is
internal internal stability rather than
uh wealth and prosperity okay all
right so that's the a quick introduction
all right any
questions about this so far are you guys
clear any
questions guys are clear right okay all
right so um that is Professor Wang y's
argument and as you can see um it's it's
he backs up with a lot of data okay um
I'm I'm just presenting to you his
argument okay so now I want to talk more
about the idea of uh the Imperial
bureaucracy
because um this will inform and help us
better understand world history as we
move along okay so to better understand
the rise of imper bureaucracy let's
let's first reexamine the history of
Rome okay so in the year
500 um
BC okay
Rome became a
republic and Rome the Republic will
become the model for for the British
Empire as well as the American Republic
okay so it's very important that you
fully understand the Rome idea of
Republic okay so now Republic is again a
society governed by
laws
tradition and
history okay and these three things are
manifested in the
nobility okay what the Romans call
patricians
patricians and the patricians will
exercise power for something called the
Senate okay and it's this very idea that
Rome is
ultimately um a culture a republic
governed by laws tradition and history
is what will allow it to expand very
quickly until it dominate the entire
Mediterranean these patricians are the
ones who will establish these
International networks that will make
the Roman Republic um coherent okay and
they will do so through the idea of a
patreon
client relationship okay so the idea is
you have a patriarch
and then the patriarch has
clients and this will
expand across the
entire um Mediterranean so in other
words the emperor is just one among
equals the emperor has his has his
Empire but these Patriarchs have their
own Empires within the Empire okay and
this gives
Rome even though it's very spread out a
um coherence and a
Unity that most Empires don't have and
again this is important for us because
the British will copy this model when
they build their empire okay as well as
the
[Music]
Americans the problem with this system
though is that um if the PS don't like
the emperor the Patriarchs can get
together and depose the emperor which
has happened a lot of times throughout
the history of the Roman Republic so
think of Julius Caesar right Julius
Caesar um wanted more power for himself
and so the Patriarchs got together and
killed him but that but Julius Caesar
was just one of many there was also Kula
uh Nero and and these um and and a lot
more Emperors Okay
so because of this new Emperors but
especially people like uh
Dian D cian was a military General who
won the Roman Civil War and so made so
became emperor they had to fix this
problem okay because obviously if you're
Emperor your biggest problem is how do
you stay
alive and in the Roman Republic uh the
chances of you staying alive aren't very
high okay so starting with Diocesan they
start to develop an imperial bureaucracy
to counter the power of the
nobility okay the problem though is that
the nobility solves three problems for
you that the broxy cannot solve okay the
first is a problem of the will to
fight the second is Unity the
third is
culture okay so the world of fight means
like in a war the nobility are those who
have the most to
lose and therefore they're the most
willing to die so think about the year
216 when HBO invaded the Italian
Peninsula and he had destroy all the
Roman armies at this point um Rome
should have surrendered but nobility
refused to surrender because
if they surrendered then Hannibal would
have instituted changes to their culture
that that would have destroyed the
prestige power and wealth of nobility
that's why the nobility refused to
surrender they fought to the very bitter
end and eventually they were able to
triumph over Carthage okay so the will
to fight the nobility gives a society
the will to fight second of course is
Unity okay National Unity the third is
culture so the people who wrote the
history of Rome were actually the
nobility the the Senators the
aristocrats okay so when you get rid of
nobility you lose these three things you
lose the idea of a national Unity a
national identity you lose culture you
lose the will to fight okay and that's
why for the longest time the system
stayed in place because to reject the
nobility to kill all the mobility would
be to destroy the tradition culture and
history of Rome all right but um
thatan would try to solve this problem
by implementing Imperial bureaucracy but
the Imperial bureaucracy could not
challenge The Authority power and
legitimacy of nobility okay that's why
Constantine would in
move the capital to by Byzantium and
create the Byzantine Empire okay and as
we discussed previously the byan Empire
folk had an imperial
bureaucracy
and it was the dominant power and so the
B Empire is not a continuation of the
Roman Empire it is rejection of the
Roman Republic okay so does that make
sense the history of Rome okay this is
important for us because the same thing
will happen in China
okay the same thing will happen in China
after the tongue Dynasty the S Dynasty
will look at the mistakes of the tongue
Dynasty and they will start to implement
a um implement the kuu system and create
an imperial bureaucracy that will um
rule China for the next Thousand Years
okay all right so the could
you there is a
great
misconception in China that the kuu is a
meritocracy but is not a meritocracy it
was never designed to be a meritocracy I
know that in school you are taught that
they have the K you in order for the
emperor to select the best and brightest
in China and because of the bright best
and brightest they will rule China
virtuously that's what you've been
taught in school that is not correct
that's not what the could you is
designed for the could is designed for
the emperor to localize the elites and
to divide and conquer them okay so let
me explain why it's not a meritocracy
first
thing first thing about theu that's
important for us is that there's a qua
system in
place okay
so if it was just meritocracy then the
very best and brightest would win out
right but think about the G cow okay if
it was just americ ocracy then who would
get get into like the top university in
China I assure you that 90% of all the
top students would come from Two Cities
right Beijing and Shanghai right but
that's not how the system works there is
a quarter system in place there's
geographic
distribution only a certain number of
students from Beijing and Shai can get
into piking and chinua the rest come
from the provinces okay the could you is
the same system so let's look at it very
quickly you at the center everyone's
trying to get into the center let's say
you have problems a b c and d and
they're all the same you have 10 wealthy
families okay and you you have
10,000 poor families okay
peasants how the system works
is a will send two D will send two B
will send two c will send two okay and
when you do it this way this creates
competition among among the local Elites
right to win these positions and
therefore they will fight amongst
themselves does that make sense if you
don't do it this way if it's just the
best and brightest then what will happen
is like a b c d and will compete compete
amongst themselves eventually one of the
provinces like maybe B will develop the
innovation in order for their children
to always finish first or place a top in
the K okay does that make sense guys all
right so it's not a meritocracy it's a
quarter system that's the first thing
second thing you need you need to
understand is that it is
unfair why is it unfair well because in
order to do on the could you remember
the could you is testing your knowledge
of something
called Wan okay or classical
Chinese classical
literary Chinese
okay this is a very hard skill to learn
it will take you decades you will need
private
tutoring your family needs to have a lot
of money you need to spend decades on
this project which means that you have a
lot of leisure time you don't have to
work okay so another in other
words only the elite families of China
can compete in the system and that's the
point okay the point is to um
concentrate the ambition and energy of
the elite families into the kuu
otherwise they might come up with ideas
like Rebellion okay they also might come
up with um new inventions and amazing
literature but they'll also probably
think of waste of Rebel okay that's why
you want to concentrate their energies
on the kuou right does that make sense
the third thing that's really important
for us to remember is
that this system is
discretionary what does that mean it
means that
just because you finished first on the
could you does not mean you become a
govern official okay do you guys
understand success on the could you does
not translate into success in politics
it is discretionary meaning the emperor
gets to decide who becomes an official
and who gets promoted only the
emperor all right and often what will
happen is the Emperor will start to
promote maybe someone from the poor
family
okay so not poor but lower nobility and
the reason why you want to do that is to
create a precarious situation in the
provinces where no family feels secure
enough to feel as though they're the
nobility okay you want to create
conflict and procurious in the provinces
that and Conquer and therefore you can
exert greater control over the provinces
but by doing that you limit economic
growth you limit C
Innovation okay does that make sense
guys all
right so what what what this means is
the bureaucracy is able
to control
China because of its Monopoly it has
Monopoly over three aspects all right
the first is
status right so if you want to be
admired if you want to be respected in
CH you do well and could you and you
become an official that's the dream of
every family in China right it's still
true today right where the dream of
every Chinese family is for you guys to
get into an i leag school and or take
the GAA and go to Ping or chinga okay
the idea of status is still associated
with the kuu even though we know that
that success on the kuu and success on
the gal does not necessarily necessarily
translate into success in school or in
life okay that's the first thing the
second
is the Monopoly over
literacy okay the Monopoly over literacy
what I mean by that is
this
in most
cultures your goal is to make literacy
more widespread because when you do that
you allow for for faster Economic
Development okay so throughout history
all cultures have tried to figure out
how to make literacy more widespread
more prevalent so let's look look at the
example of Egypt okay Egypt Egypt has
been around for as long as
China and over centuries they would make
their language a lot easier to
understand so in the beginning they had
heroglyph okay so maybe the Sun
this represent Sun this is
Moon okay so that's a first stage they
have
pictograms to
represent um ideas okay then what they
would do is make these symbols shorter
okay so that it's easier to remember and
then what what they would do is they
would make these symbols phological
meaning they don't they don't represent
ideas they represent sounds okay so this
now becomes the English word Monsoon
right does that make sense and then what
they would do is they would take the
sound sorry take take take the the word
and make it into just one consonant okay
so this would so this would become s
this will become M and therefore you now
have the word English word
sum okay and and that's how and that's
why we have the alphabet because of this
evolution of language in Egypt it was
the Egyptians who developed this system
and then the Greeks uh stole it uh
through the Phoenicians
okay all right so most cultures follow
this pattern because then because now
it's it's easier for people to become
literate which is drives economic growth
okay China is the only culture in human
history that has made literacy more
difficult over time all
right China took
the um pictograms and made them even
more complex and added these very
complex grammatical rules to the
language and created something called
literary
Chinese okay literary Chinese but that's
a nice that's a euphemism that's a nice
way of saying it it really what what it
is is bureaucrat bureaucrats
okay burees is a language that only
bureaucrats can understand so think of
contracts right when you look at legal
contracts you can't read it why because
the language the grammar is
designed so that only as a specialized
lawyer could you understand the contract
right and this is what we call Rent
seeking
Behavior you create something that only
you can use and people have to pay rent
in order uh to access your
knowledge all right
so uh literacy the problem of literacy
will keep China back uh from developing
and the third is
culture okay culture and when I mean
culture I really mean confusion
ISM so confusion confusion ism is really
a bureaucratic philosophy system
designed to maintain the status
to control how people think about the
world all right so remember in the
confusion religion what really ma what
matters first and foremost is balance
Harmony there's also a concept called an
ancestor worship so you can't leave your
village because if you leave your
village you can no longer worship your
ancestors right you can't clean their
graves and so people are just stuck in
place that limits trade and innovation
in China okay so the could you uh sorry
the bureaucracy the imper bureaucracy
was able to maintain its Monopoly over
status literacy and culture through
three mechanisms the could you L uh W
Yen literary Chinese and confusion
ISM okay and that stopped the
development
of um
that stop the cultural and economic
development of China okay so let's
better understand this idea okay in a
society there are different ways to se
to seek success and Status all right so
you have the bureaucracy of course and
that's the that's the way PE people do
it in China but you also have the
military you also have nobility right
joinan
nobility you also have church
uh religion right by becoming a priest
be by becoming a spiritual leader you
also have uh Merchants right
Commerce you can also do it through
Artistic Endeavors okay so these are the
main ways people achieve status in
society and in most societies you have
these different systems in place what is
unique about China is the dominance of
the
bureaucracy okay so the nobility was
wiped out and for the kuu uh the kuu
ensures that no nobility can arise again
in China okay um Church religion was
outlawed for most of Chinese history
okay um the merchant and the artistic
people are low status in China so go
back to the confusion system The Scholar
fishes at the top
uh then you then you have the farmers
then you have the merchants and you have
the artists right so the so the
confusion religion puts the merchants
and the artists at the very bottom and
this is intentional because the the
artists okay they they can promote new
ideas but the merchants are even more
Pro problematic because they
trade okay and they can accumulate
wealth and that wealth can challenge the
authority of the Empire all right so the
merchants are a problem the military as
we know was heavily
suppressed um throughout Chinese history
okay so the sun Dynasty there was these
massive conflicts between the military
and the bureaucracy the military want
want to go fight and defend s own
territory the Bucy wanted to just bribe
um everyone okay all
right
okay so and because you have too much
power within the bureaucracy this will
stunt development in China all right
let's look look at one more example okay
we know like by the time of the song
China had four major inventions okay
these four major inventions of course
are
paper print
making
compass and gunpowder
all right and these four inventions guys
will Revol revolutionize the world all
right so you look at paper it will give
rise to uh back notes okay so the stone
had back notes and this will give rise
to
capitalism
in the west print making is important
because remember in the 15th century uh
Gutenberg created something called the
printing press in Europe and because of
the printing press you're now able to
manufacture books at scale and when you
do that what happens is like people
become more literate okay so the very
idea of the printing press made
available all this all these books all
this knowledge that wasn't available
before and now people could just learn
how to read and write okay so this will
give rise to literacy and when you give
rise to literacy you will give rise to
things like the
Renaissance um the pro Reformation the S
Revolution the enlightenment the French
reev ution okay so this marked a
revolution in European
Affairs the compass right will allow for
the Age of Exploration so these
Europeans are able to discover new lands
and Conquer and colonize them right so
North America South America will
eventually all become colonized by the
Europeans using the compass gunpow is
important because it is the uh it is a
revolution in Warfare from gunpow you
will have things like the
cannon and also uh eventually the musket
the musket is just an individual gun and
this marks a revolution not only in
Warfare but also in human Affairs
because when when you have the musket
now individual soldiers do matter okay
before it was a
knight who was the main uh um weapon in
the Warfare but we have a must
you can
now equal the playing field okay it's
more important to have more soldiers
than you have
Knights and this will allow for things
like the American Revolution right when
you have these Farmers with muskets they
were able to overthrow the British
Empire it will give rise to the French
Revolution when you have citizens who
are not professional soldiers they're
able to take these muskets and defend
their country against a European
invasion
right so the all these are major
revolutions that will give rise to mity
okay and again China by the S Dynasty
CE had all four inventions but because
of the culture in place because of the
bureaucratic culture in
place neither not any of these
inventions had an impact in on China
China Society China did nothing
whatsoever with all four inventions
all right so the key lesson here guys
and this is really important technology
does not matter you can steal the
technology what matters is the
culture all
right another example of course is the
UN Dynasty when the UN Dynasty during
the UN Dynasty uh China was importing a
lot of foreign experts a lot of foreign
bureaucrats Christians Muslims Jews
they're in in a lot of foreign
technology and then when the M power
when the M Empire came into place they
got rid of all this stuff okay they got
rid of the foreigners they got rid of
technology and try to became much more
insular and
backward
okay okay so that explains
why the S after s Dynasty China did not
innovate anymore because the empire did
not want to innovate Innovation is a
threat to the status quo
okay and what's important is to maintain
the status quo even though by doing so
ultimately you make China um poor weak
and
divided all right good any
questions does it make sense to you
guys does is
conform to your understanding of Chinese
history
questionus
yeah okay so the question is is
confusion ISM a religion or a culture so
um no one thinks confusion is a religion
at most people say that confusion is a
Civic religion okay or philosophy all
right um so
I would say that confusion
ISM ultimately what it is is
bureaucratism I can't even SP spell
bureaucrat anymore okay bureaucratism
okay what I mean by that is that it is
something that's designed
to um make everyone believe that a
bureaucratic Society is the best Society
it is one that is uh the most
sophisticated and it it it it's it's
designed in order to maintain the status
quo where bureaucrats at the top okay
that's what confusion ISM really is so
the example is that if you re Chinese
history the most virtuous people are
always bureaucrats scholar
officials right and this propag is so
effective that eventually Europeans will
stop will will start to mimic this
propaganda so voler the French
Enlightenment thinker says that Chinese
have have the best system because they
allow only the educated to rule not
soldiers not PR but um scholar officials
mandarins okay so this is so the idea of
confusion ism is that it's bureaucratism
it's designed to legitimize and give
authority to the bureaucratic Elite
right so so so thank you
does that make sense to you
okay any more
questions okay so I'm going to end the
class with a story okay and the story
has to do with the first emperor of the
main Dynasty julan Jang so Julian Jang
he is now Emperor and he reinstituted
the kuu okay the the Mongols got rid of
the kuu um because they had a nobility
but Jan Jang he restores the kuu and
everyone was excited okay so everyone
comes and takes the
examination when the results come out
what happens is that the the um test
takers from the south do a lot better
from the north so these Northern test
takers feel there must be corruption in
place so they they they file petition to
the emperor the emperor looks at the
petition and he agrees there must be
corruption how is that no northerner was
able to pass the kuu so he calls in his
chief minister and he says this is a
huge
Scandal um I want you to resolve this
issue okay figure out who responsible
for this corruption and kill them all
right so the SC so the chief
minister um he really wants to impress
the emperor so he spend months
painstakingly
rigorously examining the issue in
investigating the issue he has
commission he has hundreds of Staff he
personally looks at every single could
you and then he writes his report he
presents to the emperor okay and he says
to the
emperor your majesty I personally have
done this
investigation and we have written like
thousands of pages of report directly to
you I can guarantee
you the kuou when implemented was a fear
open and transparent process the fact of
the matter is that people in the South
they're more civilized they're more
culture they're more educated and
therefore they just did better on the uh
they're better than the Northerners and
I'm really sorry this happened but I
guarantee you the kuu is a fair open and
transparent process you have nothing to
worry about it's all been taken care
of so what do you think think the
emperor
did what do you think the emperor
did have you guys heard heard of the
story he killed them all he killed the
um high official he killed the high
official's Commissioners he killed the
test uh makers he killed those who got
the very best scores on the kuou Okay
the reason why is the Emperor does not
want a fair open and transparent system
he wants a system in which the
localities will not rebel against the
center okay and that's what the kuu is
all right so that is it we will do
gangas Conan uh next class